Now that we've heard from some experts,
let's take some time to put
their advice into practice.
On the next screen you'll get
the repository information for a not so
well designed school
attendance application.
Clone it to your machine, check out
how it's working, and refactor it.
Make it awesome.
Now, it'll be up to you to
decide how to go about this.
Is this code completely a mess?
Is this a burn it down and
rewrite it from scratch situation?
Or are there pieces
that are salvageable?
Remember, before you start doing, take
a moment to figure out how it's working,
and what's good and
bad about the code as it is.
Evaluate how much needs to change and
figure out your strategy.
Once you're done, we'll talk
to the author of this code and
see what their motivations were for
building it the way they did.